the the invitation that god gives to the
people that he made is so so generous
and came at such a high price
he gave up the weekend that uh he gave
up a weekend
right how confident are you in defending
what you believe
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live the show where we
use the light of christ to expose the
darkness found in media
and our culture today we want to welcome
josiah to the show thank you so much for
being here enjoying and joining in the
discussion
so let's jump right into this have any
of you ever been to a satanist
temple can't say i have no
have you seen one like driving on the
street oh yeah there's a satanist temple
no okay well have you ever encountered
or talked with a satanist no you're
saying yes
yeah i was at school i was walking down
the hallway and
the school that i had was at the uh they
had a little club
we were we had a conversation because i
brought something up
in english class and they wanted to ask
me a little more about it because i was
relating
uh a character from a book that we were
reading with jesus
and he just wanted to tell me that i was
incorrect
and jesus is a fraud
and all that and honestly awesome who
was the satanist like a
fellow student yeah oh wow he was
about the same age as me okay so that
was pretty scary interesting so did they
have a christian club at your school too
or
just a satanic chess club just a
satanist club
but it wasn't it wasn't backed up by the
school it was more like we're just gonna
hang out
and do our thing but since it was a
public school
they couldn't really say no so wow
interesting
yeah when you say a satanist it's kind
of a broad term because
it is we think a satan worshiper but a
satanist will tell you we don't worship
satan we don't even believe in satan
he's kind of just like our mascot we do
what we want to do
we kind of like as long as it doesn't
hurt someone else then we can do it but
then there's others that say
well it doesn't even matter if we're
somebody else so you probably find a lot
of
atheists who could identify with a
satanist you know
right and we're going to go into that
delve into what exactly a satanist is
but before you guys get that information
because i don't know if all of you know
what exactly a satanist is what would
you imagine a satanist would look like
it's like dark dark just like
sad looking i don't know basically me
like 15 years ago
yeah i was thinking straight emo maybe
like a gold baphomet chain
god sometimes you can you can find
somebody
with good looking yeah made a lot of
money
i mean i interviewed some guy last year
some
he is now a christian but he was an
ex-satanist
and and then literally just in spanish
he's from colombia but it's 11 now he
lives in colombia
and i mean he shared a lot a lot of
things
he was like praying to satan that kind
of satanist right
yeah yeah and he was very involved um uh
heavy metal
and doing all this stuff and all the
practices and all the stuff that he
needed to do to you know worship so he
can have more money
and yeah a lot a lot of stuff
oh wow so i mean you asked that question
but i think it's fair to flip that
what's a christian look like
you know what i mean like there's we're
kind of you know stereotyping which is
what we all do
everybody's guilty of it but you know
what is a christian supposed to look
like i mean can you just walk up
to somebody on the street oh yeah you're
a christian i can tell by the way you
dress you know
yeah only if you wear our shirts but
actually you should be able to don't you
agree
it's interesting it's interesting
because
most people in society now say i'm a
christian
but like when you boil it down are you
actually
so like i you could go down the stream
be like
you're a christian and probably be right
but
most likely you're not you're just i go
in christmas and easter so now i believe
in
the man upstairs yeah so that
i feel like that the stereotype of i'm a
christian
is very loosely given and
more uh there was a quote that i really
liked that it was
christ's biggest dream is that
christians would act like him
and that was that was something that i i
read a couple years ago and i was like
you know what
i'm gonna start doing that yeah that's
true i just think it's ironic you can
cut this if you want to but
i think it's ironic that the two major
holidays that people celebrate
christmas and easter are the two ham
holidays
ham holidays yeah it's it's like you
know we're so thankful jesus that you
died so we could eat ham because you
never would
that's totally staying
[Music]
hey youtube can i trust the bible
yes you can and i'll show you why in
five minutes or less
okay so let's learn a little bit about
the church of satan okay
and stop me anytime if you guys want to
respond to anything
so as mikey was saying you're totally
right the church of satan does not
believe in the devil
neither a christian or islamic notion of
satan
so peter h gilmore which actually is a
high priest of the church
describes its members as skeptical
atheists
describing the hebrew sorry embracing
the hebrew root of the word satan which
is
do you know the hebrew root or the
meaning of satan
is it adversary adversary correct so
the church views satan as a positive
archetype
who i shouldn't be biased while reading
this i'm sorry
but the church views satan as a positive
archetype
who represents pride individualism
and enlightenment and as a symbol of
defiance against the abrahamic faiths
which anton levy you guys know him
criticized for what he saw as a
suppression of humanity's natural
instincts so the high priest um
peter gilmore has stated that my feeling
is that anybody who believes in
supernatural entities on some level
is insane whether they believe in the
devil or
god they are abdicating reason so he
goes on to say that satanism is the
beginning
has its beginning in atheism and taking
the view
that the universe is indifferent so
there is no god
and there is no devil no one cares
you know i didn't know this until i
think it was either early this year or
last year that
even in the there are some christians
that do not believe that
satan in the old testament is the same
as
satan in the new testament like they're
different beings like satan and lucifer
and
yeah they're like not the same
interesting
where i've always grown up without
understanding like okay these are just
the same being you know
old testament new testament you know it
doesn't matter same being all throughout
but there are even christians that make
a distinction between
two different beings old testament new
testament satan
i never heard that one i've heard people
think god is different in the old
testament new testament so yeah
nihilists they're like the definition
here says the rejection of all religious
and moral principles
in the belief that life is meaningless
so would they reject all moral
principles though
i know annihilus who yeah he's got some
standards
i mean how many people do you actually
know that would just say yeah go for it
rate my wife or daughter or something
you know like not too i mean to be
completely
amoral you would have to literally agree
with like
everything and say nothing exactly you
could not ever speak against anything
anybody was doing well you can't lock up
that guy from earning wait you're going
to tell me i can't lock him up why not
yeah
i can lock them up for any reason really
yeah yeah
chaos well there was an interesting
point that i that i found
see levy and the church espouse the view
that satanists are born
not made that they are outsiders by
their nature
living as they see fit um who are
self-realized in a religion which
appeals to the would-be satanists nature
leading them to realize that they are
satanists
through finding a belief system that is
in line with their own perspective and
lifestyle
now i actually agree with that when you
think about it because
all of humanity is born in a sense as
satanists
right by definition of the word and you
see that in psalms chapter 51 you know
we were born in shape and in
iniquity and christ is the one who
cleans up our hearts and makes
makes us new creatures so i hope you
stayed you know you didn't click off
because i'm not
celebrating satanism i'm just saying
that in the definition of the word
it does make sense so adherence to the
philosophy
have described satanism as a
non-spiritual religion
of the flesh or the world's first carnal
religion what do you guys think about
that
yeah like just kind of bounce off what
you're saying
in their scripture that says we're born
enemies of christ
what's a religion that's an excellent
question
for me i would say lifestyle illusion is
your lifestyle that reflects your belief
system
the world view yeah worldview
um so i found this verse in first
corinthians chapter 2
verse 14 the natural person does not
accept the things of the spirit of god
for they are folly to him
and he is not able to understand them
because they are spiritually
discerned so i could see how someone
with a satanist
mentality rejects spirituality he could
because um yeah because they didn't
accept the spirit of god
okay so by definition here's what a
religion is a belief in and worship of a
superhuman controlling power especially
a personal god or gods
so by that definition they don't have a
religion
because they don't believe in
supernatural beings
okay so how can it be classified as a
religion uh because they paid 225
dollars a month and get registered keith
yeah well that would be the only thing
because if you're saying satan doesn't
exist god doesn't exist really there is
no god
how can you have a religion yeah and how
can you get the perks of a
religious organization well you could
have a non-profit that's right some
benefits
but i don't think you could be
classified as a religious nonprofit
because you don't believe in god very
good technical
wow so or any god and ridicule those who
even believe in anything supernatural
so of course like any other i guess i
can't say religion
um belief there's a spectrum or a group
of individuals there's a spectrum so our
our thinking of what a satanist might be
or what they may believe might be
actually different from
the average satanist so i was on youtube
and i found this video from jubilee you
guys familiar with the
channel jubilee they have a series
called middle ground and i wanted us to
react to
it so this is a this is a media ministry
on a budget
i'm gonna uh ask you guys some questions
or say the statements
that they said in the video you just
have to decide whether you agree with it
or you disagree and you'll acknowledge
that by either
red you disagree or blue you agree so
please everyone
pick one red hot seat or
one blue hey this feels very political
i'll say three two one and then you put
up your decision and then we'll discuss
you can explain why
you chose your side and then you'll hear
the positions of
the people who participated in the video
okay
okay are you ready
the title of the video is can satanists
and major religions see eye to eye
okay can they
we'll answer that question at the end
all right first statement
so don't answer yet i'll give you like
two seconds to think about it and then
we'll put up our
decisions hell is a real
place hell is a real place
okay ready
read is disagree blue is agree
you agree with the blue and that is
disagree yes
all right hell is the real place three
two
one all right wow
we have agree and disagree so let's
start the tricky thing
i mean right now they're going to be
okay not right now but it's going to but
that's why i disagree a real place or no
well whether
you know we're on the same page yeah i'm
looking at it as
an event okay i would agree with you i
think and then it happens at a
a particular place and time time
but not so much like it's a place like
you can go right
on going right not like that no yeah
well i i believe that
hell is a punishment not a place because
you have all these different things you
have the lake of fire that's designated
for
satan and false prophets that's going on
over there and then you have this second
death over here and it's like it's
pretty much happening all over this
planet
so i see it more as a punishment than a
particular place like this is hell
but you said a place yeah well
because we look at the word hell in the
bible we get this picture of a pit
that's flaming or whatever but
when you look at the concordance it's
four different words
and there is a grave and there are
scriptures that say you know though i
lay down in hell you're there with me
and it's the grave and then revelation
talks about
death and hell were cast into the lake
of fire that's the act of death will be
no more
the act of being laid into a grave will
be no more there'll be no
no use for death or the grave it's going
to be gone
so yeah hell being cast to like fire has
to
be a place like not really a place
i wanted to put both up but these are
those who disagree that hell is a place
i would never worship a god
that would send someone to an eternal
lake of fire to be burned forever
for the simple fact of non-belief when
that deity knows
what it would take to convince every
single person
on this planet that is cruel it is
inhumane
it is not kind it is not generous and
that is not a god worthy of worship
well that was his answer she wasn't but
i agree with you i agree with you
if it were true i would agree did you
say disagree
he disagrees that hell is a real place
and his he gave his reasoning
and he agreed why nobody would worship a
god that would do such a thing
but what he also said was he he's
skeptical that god exists
and what he's saying is god knows
exactly
what it takes to get you to believe and
i think god's doing that all the time
but people are putting the blinders on
how many times have you
and have a non-believer talk to a
believer in the believers saying like
what about this thing that happened in
your life what about creation all this
stuff and they're just like no
no no like they're being shown god is
sending them a witness even
look at what god has done in your life
and they're like no no no
yeah i don't believe in that god either
yeah
i don't either what's more it would be
damning all i mean the vast majority of
everyone who's ever existed
for not believing in him for a set of
rules that he created
to be fair i feel like this presupposes
that
to burn in hell means that you don't
believe in god i'm sure that there are
religions and i know that there are
people who believe that
hell is a place for murderers you know
and when i was jewish
we didn't believe in hell they didn't
even talk about the devil
i just kind of came upon it myself i
believe that
in the event that we have spirits and
they will go on to some other realm it's
probably more of a nebulous place
than a physical hell lake fire
everything i don't even believe
we have souls necessarily i'd like to
see some evidence like i
barely believe that we're even conscious
like i'm about to have an existential
crisis up here
the i think oh well he's the christian
that responds you want to hear his
response
you're the only christian in the group
go for it okay the only christian
yeah christian hindu muslim wow
the historical christian position is is
that the gift of
the the invitation that god gives to the
people that he made is so so generous
and came at such a high price
a high price he gave up the weekend that
uh he gave up a weekend
right he was god before yeah yeah
he was gone during and he's god now he
gave up a weekend
if i knew right now that i could
go off and die and then not die
how where's the gift in that number one
i'm able to look at
the the grace that has been extended to
me and
okay so the way that i would commonly
think of it is that if i gave up
the life of of my own son uh
in exchange for your life that that is
okay then for me
to to make the the invitation that god
makes towards us
is that moral is it moral is it moral on
a corporeal level
jesus took on the penalty that i deserve
for the the sins that i committed
if we're looking at you know the
traditional christian faith and so i
receive uh his gift of grace and as as
a payment for for the things that i had
done so your question is it moral or is
it just
is it fair i'm able as a christian to
say no it's not fair um
because i deserve the punishment that he
took on himself
good hold it down okay okay cool
i believe in good and evil
all right unanimously awesome so why
why do you believe that because you can
see it since the beginning
there is good and evil it says in
revelation
that there was war in heaven so if there
is war
means there's two sides there is good
and evil
yeah absolutely and yeah it literally
started at the beginning genesis chapter
3 verse 5 when satan is talking to
well satan the serpent is talking to eve
he actually says the words good and evil
and he's like lying to her like god
wants to withhold good and evil from you
if you eat the fruit
you will be like god um knowing good and
evil so i mean good and evil is
throughout the entire bible
but he was doing something deceitful i
mean that's that's evil i mean how are
you gonna
you know i mean what is the good thing
about it you know
you're deceiving i mean he was deceiving
a uh eve a person
well she had no days i mean you just
even if you have no moral compass then
what's deception it's just something
that you have to do to get what you want
i mean that's kill or be killed
perfectly okay for somebody to do back
to you as well
that's right right that's as i was going
to say
it's kind of along the same lines of
like that moral compass if you
if you take the bible away like you
don't even look at it
you're raised with okay this is right
this is not right and so
either way you know people have that
sense of what is right what's wrong yeah
yeah it's written on our heart
right and wrong has always regardless of
what
you're raised as you have an idea of
what's right and wrong
yeah so even if you're in a different
culture it's all the same
so cool well let's hear the argument
yeah i think the phrasing is something
that's
what it's it's a little bit catchy yeah
i believe in right and wrong and i think
some things for me a lot of things lie
in the gray area but there are some
things that i consider right and wrong
but i wouldn't say it's the same as good
and evil did she say some things were
right and wrong
right so she says there's right there's
wrong but majority of things are in the
gray area
something something so like i've heard
somebody say
what's good sometimes something good is
not right
and sometimes that's something that is
right it's not good
for example sinning is good it's not
right
something like that yeah like it feels
good yeah but it's not right
so some i can attest to this personally
i've had a lot of different
opportunities open up for me
and they're all really really good
opportunities but the way i look at it
is
yes they're good opportunities but are
they the right opportunity
like so the way i'm doing it is if god
wants me to go a certain way
that's the right way i should be going
not just because
it's flashy and it's okay and it's
morally all right
that's not the right way it's why waste
my time with all these good things
when i should be doing the right thing
so i guess my thing is if it's not right
how can it still be good for you uh
that's what i was thinking okay what
about pizza you know i mean
eating pizza you know 24 hours or every
day
for seven days you know yeah i mean if
it's it's
good i mean that's good but it's not
right for me
why because you know i mean gain weight
or your disease or
you know all pills and everything so
what is the good and
right there yeah i think i think we're
talking about slightly two different
things
because when she's talking about
right and wrong that's in the context of
morals
good and evil are also describing
in the realm of morals we're not talking
about the physical properties
of an object or personal desires
so it really depends it depends on how
it's defined
the way she's talking about it um
i i'm having a hard time wrapping my
mind around that it could
that there are things that are right
that could be
evil or that are good and could be wrong
maybe like to be a stripper is a good
job opportunity to make money but is it
morally right well it's not illegal
but then but then i would have to
question whether or not it's good
see because we're talking about in the
moral sense is it good in the moral
sense for her
to be a stripper no well does she make
money off of it
yes making money there's nothing wrong
with making money
but is it good for her to do that job in
the moral sense i would say no because
it's
demeaning to her and it's probably
costing her more in the end than she's
making
i think that would depend on your moral
compass though there's a lot of people
they're like i love it just take me sure
and then that but it goes back to
definitions what are we saying what are
we saying
is right and wrong right how is that
being defined and then how is good and
evil being defined and are we talking
about
morals or are we talking about desires
are we talking about physical properties
these are all different things
i think if you look at it from a
perspective
of and i'll use this example it's pretty
extreme but
like killing right we can all say
that you should not do it like just
across the board don't do it
morally it's wrong however there are
times where you
do it because you have to right
also god did tell people to go
literally murder people in cold blood
so i feel like that example of evil
things
can be good that would be
my way to argue that point pretty good
exactly that would definitely be a great
area for sure yeah
exactly so where she's like there's a
lot of things that are in the gray area
i would definitely put
that and i would argue
you know it's evil to do that it's bad
to do that
but god's action is bad no to
kill people well you're saying killing
people is bad and god directed the
killing so god's action is bad so god
did something bad
i'm saying that no
in that circumstance an evil thing can
be good
but the bible also says in isaiah 5 20
well unto them that call evil good and
good evil
that put bitter for sweet and sweet for
better
so yeah you know
we that's that's a tricky spot to get
we'll see
we'll agree it's in the gray area so we
don't i don't know that it is in the
gray area
because you're you again it goes back to
definitions you're saying
that elijah went and murdered those guys
i think there's a difference between
murder
which is a premeditated intent
to do something in cold blood and what
you're talking about
is essentially a divine judgment from
god
he told him go and do this
they are carrying they are the
instrument to carry out god's
judgment now the tricky part that we
have in our day and age is
we live in a slightly different time
we don't live in a theocracy anymore
right and so there is no one going
around
as the instrument of divine judgment
right god has reserved that now till the
end of time where he will
come with his reward and he will pass
judgment so
i would say there's a difference between
an individual being asked to carry out
divine judgment
and murder right and that's again it
goes back to definitions what are we
talking about
otherwise you're going to get in that
tricky spot of well then god
what he did was bad but we're calling it
good so is god
good or is god bad or is his actions
evil
right you get in a tricky spot
this is good great conversation i
believe satan is evil
three two one
alex is not sure no i was just thinking
which one it is
okay why why do you believe satan is
evil
because okay
i mean the first thing he must be sinful
deceitful okay and then he was
uh what we call that he
is uh trying to cause war in heaven
he caused chaos he makes people do
evil stuff yeah he's evil
he was a liar from the beginning and
he's a
murderer seeking who he can devour
bible says by your fruits you'll know
why by their fruits you shall know them
so kind of put on put that on himself
i'm a very simple thinker when it comes
to this
like you must be like really really bad
to have your creator kick
kick you out like that
it's pretty bad yeah i think the real
bad is that
he was a creator being and he wants to
fight back to his creator
yeah you know as a creature and a
creator he said hey
i want to you know i know words like hey
i want to destroy you you don't say i
want to be above that's what the bible
is saying i said
that i want to put my throne about the
stars
so this again
you know keep hammering this thing of
definitions evil means profoundly
immoral and wicked
so evil only has meaning if you believe
that there is morality
right if you're an amoral person and
like these people that were
talking about in the beginning in the
show that are satanists they don't
believe in a supernatural god
for a supernatural being on either side
then there is no evil
no because there are no morals so there
is no right and wrong it's all
relativism
i can do whatever i want so we'll do
what thou will because we believe
that there are morals then yes we
believe in evil
that means there can be profound
immoral and even wicked uh
things yeah yeah well the bible
references the devil as the evil one
like throughout the bible and actually
jesus went in on satan
in john chapter eight is it john yeah
john chapter 8
verse 44. so he says and he's talking to
the scribes and pharisees at this point
he's like
ye are of your father the devil
and the lusts of your father ye will do.
then he says he referenced saying the
devil was
a murderer as michelle was saying from
the beginning and abode not
in the truth because there was no truth
in him when he speaketh a lie
he speaketh of his own for he is a liar
and the father of it now that's not
clear yeah
so is the question i guess would be is a
liar and a murderer
a bad person and if the satanist can't
say yes to that then we got issues
okay you guys have to go but don't
forget to subscribe awesome channel
real life studios english and spanish
see ya
let's listen to what they have to say
this will be interesting
so let's go back to genesis okay god
wanted to keep
humans from eating the fruit of
knowledge correct
and satan or the serpent wanted to give
humans that knowledge
i believe that's a good action that is a
good action
that's a good action that's justifiable
yeah i knew this is where this is going
okay
that's always the argument that's
ignorance
why because she she
she does not even know what genesis 3
says
what does it say
the tree is the fruit of the knowledge
of good and
evil it's not just the fruit of
knowledge
so if you're looking at it like it's
just a fruit of knowledge
then we've just taken a sharp turn to
gnosticism
right it's interesting and because
gnostics say the same thing they say
that okay well
all the serpent wanted to do was to
uh and yeah to give knowledge and
knowledge is a good thing
so that's why they flip the story and
you see this in the hollywood tv movies
and
music videos and all kinds of stuff all
the time
they flip that on its head and that's
why you see
you know this character that looks a lot
like christ
having the attributes of satan and
that's why you see this satan like
character having the attributes of
christ they just flip the model on its
head
so she's ignorant of this story which
doesn't surprise me because
she's a satanist why would she be you
know extremely educated
i mean i'm not educated on the book of
satan so if i tried to speak
intelligently on that
i'm sure i would get it wrong i mean it
just makes sense
i would ask her if knowledge of good and
evil is a good thing
then let me have your child for a few
days and just show them
everything i can all the knowledge of
good things and evil things and do
you want your kid to see all that you
want your kids to see
hey this is the first
person to advocate for equal rights yes
we only heard god's perspective
and for my personal i mean just looking
into the bible it's like we didn't hear
satan's perspective
maybe he said this is god is a
tyrannical god and i'm going to rebel
from him
and i'm going to become a fallen angel
to help the creator
my interpretation and understanding of
that story is is that god created an
environment where he
and it was environment of love and peace
and and where his
children that he created and who he
loved who he created in his image
they were naked and they didn't have
understanding yeah yeah and that they
would
did you hear what he said yeah yeah
i was like wow what a punk
i'm not trying to be disrespectful of
that guy but he is intentionally
goading this guy yeah and so he's really
you know the guy is
he's outnumbered for one everybody else
there doesn't
you know they're not a christian yeah
and so they're all kind of like
ganged up on this one guy and just
taking shots at him
and so yeah he's gonna seem a bit
flustered and i probably would too you
know
it's like you're the one in the hot seat
you're the one that has to provide all
the answers
and everybody there doesn't agree with
you and wants to attack you and
shoot shut you down and if you don't
have all the answers they walk away
feeling yeah
like they won but they're not going to
have all the answers either and it's
okay
and you could just tell you know he's
kind of sitting back like smugly like
just
you know taking his jabs and so that's a
punk thing to do
one thing i notice is they're nev they
never defend their own stance they're
always attacking christianity and
christianity's beliefs
so if i were to watch that and walk away
i'm like well i didn't really
learn much about satanism i just see
hateful
hurt people trying to attack this one
guy yeah because like i said i would
have a lot of questions for them you
don't believe in morality
you are okay with knowledge of good and
evil this is not a dialogue it's it's a
rant session and it was environment of
love and peace and
and where his children that he created
and who he loved who
he created in his image they were naked
and they didn't have understanding
yeah yeah and that they would this was
an environment for them to
so we got it
uh to flourish and so he puts them in
this environment and he desires for them
to
to to flourish and to be and to live in
in
in unashamed relationship with him and
his perfection and his glory and
and stupid i see god making simple play
things because he's bored
if it's real then and then saying don't
do this because i don't want you on my
level
and if you do i have to make sure you
can't live forever so you really don't
get on my level
would you think that if you heard that
you're one of your friends was having a
baby and
and you'd say oh you're just making a
play thing for your different
intentions there are some parents who
use
and to say that you know humanity was
just god's play things he just
threw them out there no genesis 2 is
quite clear
man was given a job how can you do a job
if you're stupid or you don't know what
to do
the the other interesting thing is if
you think about it
it's like why does adam
mention that he's naked later
it's a realization that he comes to
after sin i'm naked like i don't think
he was walking around before
he's naked and all of a sudden because
of sin it's like whoa like
i didn't know this i'm naked like what
in the world yeah
in other words the implication is there
was something
covering them right now the bible
doesn't explicitly
say there was something covering them
but if you read between the lines and
think about it
there's something covering them
otherwise he wouldn't be all of a sudden
like oh
i'm i'm there's nothing covering me yeah
and if revelation is really just
bringing us back to
the perfect plan which was eden
revelation doesn't say that we're going
to be naked
so they're gonna be all wearing white
robes and stuff so
yeah i believe that they were wearing
something
interesting observation just in the
bible in general
satan is always trying to
uncover stuff take clothes off you know
in society jesus is the one that's
always covering things
covering your sins covered them after
they realized they were naked
right that's true that's the first thing
you did that's the first thing he did
yeah so it's not like let's not give god
any credit for that though right
well yeah that's like the only reason
such an interesting point so this this
satan who is giving them this knowledge
and enlightenment
left them naked to go wonder and it's
god who came in and clothed them out let
me cover you
wow let me take care of this yeah it
wasn't like now that you've eaten the
fruit let's go
do something you know you're just off
the scene it was just one
disappeared wow okay ready for the next
one
yeah okay so the statement says religion
has
caused more harm than good
i need my friends okay i don't know
like this wrong i was actually
um i'm going to say misunderstood
religion or i would add that people who
don't understand
who fully understand their religion that
is what has led to more harm than good
that's my stance
there are a lot of different religions
what i was thinking so that's what i was
thinking
there's a lot of religions okay i mean
yeah
you know we're doing child sacrifice
that does a lot of harm yeah
now if you said christianity has caused
more than
you could still i don't know if you say
more but
this caused a lot of harm just because
people like twist it and use it
for their own game because on a global
scale it's christianity that's kind of
had its hands all over the globe whereas
child sacrifice is more in certain parts
of the world so
when you think more harm than good
that's that's where my mind went
christianity is truth and
satan is satan's not going to win
followers by just giving you an anti
that or a lie he's going to use the
truth and twist it and make it have all
these errors
and that's how he's going to gain the
most people is through
false interpretations of the truth
absolutely
so um with the argument you know
religion i'm going to
pinpoint and say christianity and people
think of like the crusades and
things that just abuses have happened in
the name of god and they're like well
look at that
that's way more harm than good and i
would argue uh james 1 27
they weren't following true religion
true christianity
which is simply put like this james 1 27
pure religion and undefiled before god
and the father is this
to visit the fatherless and the widows
in their affliction
and to keep himself or herself unspotted
from the world what i see here is
charity empathy and devotion to christ
once you follow those three i don't
think there's any way you can go wrong
and cause more harm than good
it seems like we have a shirt about that
yeah you can get that shirt on
teespring.com
nice plug so i say i agree that religion
caused
more harm than good i guess it's because
the modern
religion that like a wrong description
of religion that people have now because
it seems like religion that people have
now
is everybody think they are truth
they are the best and not all of them
but a lot of them they tend to belittle
other religion it costs more harm
this is the true definition of religion
that's a very small
piece of the world right now so yeah
it's probably doing more harm than good
because
there's so little of this well let's
hear what these guys have to say
religion has caused more harm than good
oh satanists religion has caused a lot
of harm
is is it the ultimate source of evil no
ultimately people make their own
decisions but
we talk about crusades and which trials
and the god hates
and the and and the snake handlers and
the
and and the the persecution
subjection of science the arts i mean i
don't know that there's been a major war
that hasn't
been at least fueled by religion if not
directly started by it some of them were
just political things but they were
always
had a religious backing at some point
that like flared the fire up and made it
so much
worse than it would have been and they
vote yeah so i was talking to a friend
and you know they were just like really
over the church and just like done and
were
actually going on to be done with god
too because of the people what the
people were doing in the church
and i had to really ask them to separate
the two
separate god from religion because
you know if i i'm going to use michelle
as an example go up to michelle and say
in the name of jesus and punch her
across the face
because i claim to be a christian i am
not
actually adhering to god and his
principles and what's in the bible
and i was just admonishing her like
please like um
the church as it's always said is a
hospital for sinners you know you're not
going to find anyone perfect within the
church within the religion
there's a lot of just misunderstanding
and misinterpretation within the church
and then there's god
how about having a personal relationship
with god understanding who
he is not someone who's claiming to know
him but him himself go and talk to
him read about him and and find truth in
him instead of
religion that's a that's an interesting
point
i i have a friend um
and they were brought up kind of
in the uh i
know there's something but i don't know
what it is
kind of mindset and her mom was raised
as a catholic and she i was talking to
her
for a while uh one day and she was just
like you know
i i just kind of gave up you know
because there's so many rules there's so
many things
religion and church are there's just
so many things that you have to do to
get this
and i was really just like
sad for her because if you think about
it
the rules that god gave us are moral
rules that we kind of follow already
and for you to go beyond that and to say
well now you have to pay and now you
have to go kiss some statues toes now
you have to go do this it's just
who wants to do that right so
i think i agreed that it does
cause more harm because you do have
these people
that are brought up in the church and
they think okay well i'm catholic or i'm
baptist or i'm this i'm that
and this is what it is
and then you get older and you start
understanding what's going on you're
like
well they're just taking my money i
don't need this
and then you just disown god completely
right exactly
so regardless of what religion you go to
there's always going to be that extreme
of people that just say i'm done
completely
yeah that was that's where i get my my
thinking that religion is more of a
lifestyle because growing up in in a
religious
household you follow a certain lifestyle
then you grow up and you're like oh i
don't agree with this so then you detach
yourself from not only a lifestyle but
the god that
was attached to that so i think we kind
of have it backwards
but i guess as for children you have to
teach them and for them to be in the
lifestyle but someone coming into the
faith at an age where they can reason i
think the first step is
understanding who god is and then
finding a lifestyle that matches with
what you've read in the bible
you find that religion that matches with
that's interesting too because something
when people ask me all the time
and i'll use the same person they were
like okay so what do you
what do you suggest doing i was like
well that's an easy question
read the book of john that's it first
thing you do
don't read genesis because you won't
understand it if you don't understand
john you won't understand revelation if
you don't understand genesis
so just start in the middle go to the
beginning gets the end
that's and you'll just get the whole
idea
i don't know if they actually did that
but that that's kind of my advice
because
to understand the religion you're in you
have to understand how
that religion got there you know welcome
scotty
yeah we started off talking about
satanism
nice in the church of satan and now
we're looking at um
a video from jubilee you're familiar
with jubilee the youtube channel
okay i didn't know they weren't just saw
the video but it's like a debate thing
i've seen
this channel before okay so the title
can satanist and major religions see eye
to eye
[Laughter]
yeah so we're just going through the
video yeah
everything that they talked about in
their response
was the actions of the adherents
which didn't get to the heart of what
the religion taught exactly
and so that's
a that's an interesting thing and i
think for them it's a slippery slope
because the bible says by their fruits
you will know them
and yes there are people who claim to be
christian and their fruits
are lacking but
they're also because they're on the
attack in this whole video
they're not talking about changed lives
or the good that's been done
right so show me
somebody who's converted to satanism
that has
changed the world for a better place or
stopped
beating their children because
of it you know they were an alcoholic
before and then beat their children and
you know what i mean in other words show
me the fruit for the transformation of a
life
out of that and what they're not
addressing
are the hundreds of thousands of
millions of people
who have come to christ and been
transformed
your extreme examples are always going
to be the ones in the headlines
but your your transformations
don't always make the headlines you know
they happen day by day
little by little and
i mean satanism is self-centeredness
right if you talk or if you actually
watch any um interviews from any
satanists
they'll tell you straight out we don't
even believe in satan
it's really about worshiping ourselves
so i think it's very
opposite of the idea of christianity
where
it's about other people going and giving
your resources to the homeless and
you know i don't know if you guys
brought this up before but when there's
a natural disaster that happens i don't
really see
very many satanists running in there
helping people right yeah who's always
going in there first
the christian and so you know i think
just
just diabolically i don't see how they
get the eyeball to eyeball if one
person's selfish and the other one's
selfless it's it's interesting because
they were
the earlier uh it was brought up that
uh whatever happens you have to be okay
with it
like there was that idea that well
nothing really matters
who cares you know a couple years ago
i don't know if it happened but they
were talking about
taking down the ten commandments it was
like that huge statue thing and they
wanted to replace it
with their statues yeah if you really
don't care
just put it next to it or like on the
other side of town
don't put it right where that is you
know what i'm saying
especially and that also means that you
have to go to
each courthouse each
historical monument that has the ten
commandments engraved in it
buff it out and then
so if you really like don't care
why is it a big deal to take down
something that's a pillar
in our
foundation yeah but it also as a country
too
but i would also ask the question um you
know if they have such a problem with
the ten commandments are you okay with
killing
you okay with stealing you okay with
cheating on your spouse are you okay
with these things right
and you i'm sure if you ask that
question to a satanist
oh you know i don't know if that's okay
right i don't need your book
yeah they're gonna adhere to those same
things that are supposedly supposed to
be making life
better i'm sure they'll disagree with it
with the god thing maybe they want other
gods i can understand that but yeah the
first four commandments
come from i wonder if you tell them hey
our laws
came like when they first like the
constitution
was kind of based off of
religious it was it was actually amazing
if you tell them i wonder what they
would say
now it's case law yeah so now it's like
they've
they've gone from looking at a moral
standard and saying
okay we're going to judge everything
against this to now oh well this other
guy got off for this so
there you for you can get off for this
or this other guy got pinned for this
so now you're gonna get pinned for this
and that's just like
yeah it used to be like all humans have
unalienable rights or something we're
all created
in the image of god and stuff but yeah
to bounce off what you're saying like
i've brought it up before you know
and and these people should understand
that if christianity disappeared
overnight
how many hospitals will be gone how many
soup kitchens we go on homeless shelters
women
beat battered women's all these great
things
and who's going over there to help the
third world countries
you know missionaries are flying over
there with uh
food and literature and stuff and how
many atheists do you see like yeah i'm
going over there for a month and help
build a well in a school and all these
things and to be honest
like if you i like if you look at this
from a like step back you see this war
that's going on
if you could see through the portals of
everything and see this this
you know enemy that's engaged in
fighting against humanity or whatever
right
they're spending their legion of attack
on christianity like like people that
look at christianity go oh it's so
messed up and there's things
well yeah because they got the they got
the the
most energy aimed at them to try to
manipulate them and change them and so
yeah the church has
problems why because you've got you've
got a lot of people
the evil angels fighting against us so
you know i think you're right if you
took away all those elements
churches you know hospitals things that
christianity is trying to
hold back those those winds of strife i
mean
this place would just self-destruct
okay ready for the last one scotty red
pin is disagree blue pin is agree
it's a statement i respect all
religions ready three two
one wow so tricky
okay before agree to
disagree why do you disagree keith
well i guess on a technicality i'm
not aware of all religions
so i can't say i respect them all um
two i don't know
that i would say that i respect
atheism as a religion
because it doesn't fit the definition of
a religion
um but i would clarify and say
i respect all those people um
the religion is another issue because
it's the root of what
it is teaching the adherents
so i don't know that i respect all of
those because i don't agree with all of
their
all the principles of every religion but
i respect all the people
that adhere to those different religions
why do you guys agree that you respect
all religions i think it's
that you know for me it doesn't mean i
risk
i agree with all their belief and like
child sacrifice thing but i respect the
people because
uh maybe that's the best thing that they
know they grow up with
so i respect them but i don't respect
their
their religion itself okay yeah red pen
i guess that's all right that was a
tricky question if you were to rewind
you'd see me being like
but uh yeah same kind of thing i i
respect freedom of choice
yeah i think god is pro-choice even
you know i don't want to go down the
road but he respect he's
he's pro-choice in the fact that he
allows you to make the choice but there
will be consequences for your choices
and i am all for
freedom in that sense now
i would like to talk with those people
and and
try to show them why i don't agree with
what they believe or whatever but
they have every right to believe it you
want to clarify
you're you think god has prayed truth no
no let's see if he gets his attack as i
got attacked
i'll just say god is giving you the
choice
to do that but just make sure nothing
gets construed
the wrong way yeah so for those
wondering what we're talking about
check out our video called hollywood in
politics
i i kind of view it as the way that
that god has allowed creation to to
make these very terrible decisions and
he is not
immediately you know like okay i'm gonna
just punish this one and do away with
this one there will be a final
punishment of your actions if you're
killing your children
you're gonna have to answer to god for
that but i think
in the same way i think that
what this country was based on the idea
of being able to worship
upon the dictates of what you feel like
is between you
and god or your god or whatever i think
that in order for that freedom to happen
you have to allow that person they're
gonna some are gonna worship satan
some are gonna worship this thing over
here and so it's like to have that
freedom over here
you have to be like what the way god
treats it some people are going to
totally abuse that
and and go over there but you're i think
i mean i'm going to take this maybe
in a turn but you're you're saying
you're saying freedom and respect
are the same thing i'm saying i can
disrespect
what your religious belief your
religious construct is and that has
nothing to do with your personal freedom
no that's tricky disrespect meaning like
like what i'm not saying your religion
shouldn't be allowed oh okay i'm saying
i disagree
with the your your root teachings
that that religion is teaching yeah it
doesn't mean that i'm
there to like shut it down and like
squash it out
i'm just saying i don't have the same
respect for that
as i do other things like christianity
but you would be
you would be of the courteous opinion
that you you would i mean
i i i'm against killing children so if
you're killing children yeah
there should be some lines here but i
mean to the most part
however you worship even if it's like in
a
solely selfish environment like satanism
i think that you you should be allowed
to be able to do that
like it's it's a platitude of all
religions to say
i respect your religion i respect your
religion i respect your religion but
you're all saying oh i respect your
right to have that religion but then
internally you're saying allah is the
only god jesus
is not god visnu krishna these are gods
these are deities
jesus christ is the only way he is the
answer he is the only one
i'm right you're all wrong but i'm going
to be nice about it
yeah basically yeah
like everyone's going to feel like their
way is the right way
yeah we were kind of talking about
respect you know i'm thinking like if i
went into
a buddhist house and they got this
temple and they're like oh
be respectful i'm not going to go over
there and be like what this don't mean
anything you know or whatever
he doesn't agree that they're all right
he only agrees that he only thinks he's
right so what's the difference
i don't think you would you know i don't
think anybody that's worshiping in a
religion it's like i'm worshiping the
wrong one
that's what he's saying he's saying he
doesn't respect all religion so he's
saying by
them saying that they do it's actually
not true because they're thinking that
they're right and all the rest are wrong
i guess you'd have to really define
respect yeah because
because respect to me and my mind is
like
i'm i'm allowing you the space to to
live out your life
as you you see fit um that doesn't mean
yeah a disrespect to that would be like
no i'm going to pretty much not let you
do that
yeah so here's our definition i've done
this like three times already on the
show
respect the feeling of deep admiration
for someone or something elicited by
their abilities qualities or
achievements
there's a second definition due regard
for the feelings wishes rights or
traditions
of others yeah it would be hard to say
you have
that for every religion maybe some
others but would occur a more
appropriate appropriate word to be
tolerance
okay so there's a lot of things you
don't tolerate
so let me ask you this did jesus respect
the pharisees
he called him hypocrites and everything
you brewed a viper
yeah white wash tombs i think if if you
go by this definition a feeling of deep
admiration for someone or something
elicited by their abilities qualities
or achievements you know
you really start to wonder does jesus
have respect
for any of us but then you you i could
say that um
the fact that he was doing those things
calling them out on stuff wanting them
to change
is a form of respect because he cares
for them
i think the parent would rebuke you
caring for them is not the same as
having
admiration for what they've done i think
it was
more of like uh
okay you're you're a priest
you're held to a higher standard
and what you're doing is not
meeting that bar so i'm going to be
extremely brutally honest of how
god feels
but i do respect you
or i admire you because you are a priest
which means you do have that higher
standard and
society sees you that way so i will
treat you that way but
i'm going to be brutally honest with how
i actually think about you
well i mean jesus saying you know if you
were blind you would not be held
accountable for the sin
but you say that you see so therefore
i'm holding you accountable for your sin
um yeah they were held to a different
standard
and he was calling them out because they
they were the gatekeepers they were the
ones that were supposed to be the
educators
yeah and they were the they were the
ones that were actually keeping the
people in the dark so
he called him out about it personally
i'm gonna call this says
i don't think jesus has a lot of respect
for
by this definition what i think jesus
has is a lot of love
and you know we we probably think of
this
in terms of respect like how we see it
what is respectful back then
their time words of definitions even
change there's probably close to 500
words in the king james bible that don't
mean the same thing to
us now as they did when they were
written
um but
so it's it's you have to be careful
about how you define those i mean
there's this same group of people jesus
called them
vipers and brute hypocrites you know and
it's like by
by our definition if you've seen
somebody who's like an educated
high member of society to call them a
snake
and a hypocrite would not be a very
respectful thing to do
by our own uh the way that we deal with
now but
he loved and he cared about them
and that's why he did what he did but i
don't know that he quote unquote
respected them
i really hope we get a replay because
there are some comments that jesus threw
out like
are you that dull it's just like
i really want to know if that was lost
in translation or
how did that really come out you know is
he really just calling him you
idiot i wonder if he said it as like
calmly and like you're an idiot
i think that there's a difference
between believing that
somebody else's religion is wrong and
respecting it i feel like you can have
respect
and still disagree and that's where i'm
kind of coming from and
i disagree with all of you guys on your
religious beliefs but of course
everybody disagrees on their religious
beliefs i think we all disagree with
each other to a certain extent but we
can all live in harmony and we can't
respect the other person's views
i think that is an excellent point i
respect someone's
you know someone's really into that like
i've had these conversations with
buddhists
and i've actually recently had a
conversation with a with a buddhist and
he just went on and on and on about his
buddhism and this and that and he was
kind of blending these ideas with
christianity
and i just kind of sat and i listened
you know and i didn't just like rebuke
him or be like nah dude that's
what whatever that's not true and i kind
of just listened to him
and then did not like slam him for like
what he believed
and then i kind of and i kind of just
said well i actually kind of see it a
little bit like this
and i just shared my understanding of
the way things were
out there with him but i think i i came
at that with it with a reproach of like
i i respect where you're coming from and
the fact that you're really seeking out
something greater
i would hope that you're you know open
to truth if god shows it to you
and um you know but in my head i was
like man this guy's way off
all right so back to the original
question can satanists and other
religions
specifically christianity see eye to eye
no no
i don't think they're compatible i don't
either they're complete opposites they
are completely okay
yeah it's okay could i have a decent
conversation with a satanist sure
absolutely and and would i want to share
um
you know my world view or my truth with
him then yeah
i would certainly try but um you know if
he
i think you have to kind of allow that
same sort of space if he's just like
trying to share his religion
you know if you're gonna expect him to
listen to you you would have to
at some point listen to what he has to
say don't be combative about it
actually it's really in the silence
because a lot of times we're trying to
show so much quote unquote truth and
we're just adding fuel to the fire for
them to just
knock things down and then we're in the
position of
man well i didn't think about that wait
how much this response to that it's like
we're digging a hole whether and
what's better it would be if we would
just stop and listen just as jesus did
he stopped and listened any asked
questions
you know following his example well i
had this other question written down but
keith kind of
i think we may have to reword it because
it's can satanists and christians
respect each other and i was like oh
absolutely but i don't think
that's accurate anymore what's a
different question i guess live in
harmony
i admire your dedication
[Laughter]
well my argument is that jesus offers
the same gift of salvation to them
as he does us so i guess in a way we
should have
love for them we should care about them
and their well-being
and always be willing and ready to offer
or to answer their question or to have a
conversation with them they shouldn't be
oh you're a satanist i'm going to walk
away now because yeah i'm not trying to
involve myself in that you can smile and
in your head you'll be like someday
you'll know the whole truth
[Laughter]
yeah i just want you guys really to
remember james chapter 1 verse 27 and
dealing with anyone
there's no instruction that says do this
and that excluding satanists or any
group of people outside of christianity
no we're supposed to
visit the widows and and orphans across
the board
i'm glad i jumped in at the end here no
idea what you said in the beginning but
this is great so i'd like to leave you
guys and
those watching with two main points as
we wrap up here one as christians um
we have a bigger responsibility than
just living on this planet
and that's clear in matthew chapter 28
the great commission
so um there's there's a saying that goes
you don't really understand something
unless you can explain it to your
grandmother
you get it i tried to teach your email
once it didn't work
so the bible says in uh first peter
chapter 13 verse 15
to sanctify yourselves sorry sanctify
the lord god in your hearts
and be ready always to give an answer to
every man
not everyone except satanists or
everyone except the person that doesn't
agree with you
to give an answer to every man that asks
you a reason of the hope that is within
you
with meekness and fear now the word fear
there actually synonyms of it
is with reverence how can you give an
answer if you don't have one
how can you explain something that you
don't understand
so something to keep in mind it's
important and comforting to know that we
aren't
alone in this and we shouldn't be
totally dependent on our knowledge
anyway
the holy spirit is with us and wants to
help us
god promises that he will tell us what
to say
when we need to say it the second thing
is uh people
have a knack of making things more
complicated than they really are have
you experienced that
yeah especially when money's involved
yeah yeah you won't understand it just
pay me and i'll do it
you know so and throughout history the
history of christianity
there have been so many falsehoods and
abuses done in the name
of the bible in the name of christianity
and even today the christian lifestyle
is deemed
impossible in this day and age and how
could you like
you're so dated in all of these things
but
um get this that was actually the view
in biblical times as well
and when you really look at it
christianity is
pretty simple i just find this
interesting that god himself
speaks in the bible and he lets us know
what he's expecting from us as
christians
and it's in micah chapter six and i
encourage all of you to actually read
that whole chapter
because um well micah chapter 6 verse 8
is the verse that i'm referencing
but before that god actually gives these
examples of what people are coming to
him
and saying should i do this should i do
that and they're all these crazy extreme
things
and after verse 8 he actually goes on to
explain
what's to come for those people who have
been deceitful about his words
but micah chapter 6 verse 8
says he hath showed thee o man what is
good and what does the lord require of
me
but to do justly and to love mercy
and to walk humbly with our god man
that's so complicated
what do you think what do you think
about that three steps
and and it's just repeated and enlarged
throughout the entire bible maybe said
in different ways but at the core
it's saying the same thing it's an
interesting verse that i think of that
goes along with that
in a somewhat indirect way i think it's
amos 3 3
can two walk together except they be
agreed yeah
you know so if you're going to walk with
god they'll be on the same page
yeah so i shall not take the lord thy
god's name in vain
that's not just saying omg or whatever
that's saying
i'm a christian and look at all the
things that you do that
aren't christian like it's making god
look bad
well thank you guys for playing this
little game for using the props
and we hope you learned something today
if you did please
like and share this video all over the
interwebs
and we just thank you so much for your
love and support and we encourage you to
gain
your our own personal understanding of
the bible so that you will be
able to accurately and confidently
share the love of jesus christ thank you
all for watching we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign